welcome back to the rockstars i'm eric
voss an hour
uncovered one clue all the way back in
phase one of the mcu that is now
reportedly gonna play a huge role in
upcoming phase events like a fifth
avengers film and secret invasion
marvel's illuminati teased as an easter
egg icon on tony stark's phone during
the senate hearing in iron man 2
and is now reportedly in development by
marvel and kevin feige according to a
cast listing reported recently by
illumineerde
a phase 5 adaptation of the secret
superhero cabal of leaders and upon
close re-examination of tony stark's
earlier actions
i think i have uncovered a discreet
contingency plan by the man of iron
a secret weapon that he gradually
tinkered together in the background
of the infinity saga operation
illuminati coming in avengers 5
which we will explore in this episode of
the weapons of marvel
or conspiracy but you know there's also
a splash of scroll search in here
okay so what is marvel's illuminati in
2005 brian michael bendis introduced the
illuminati in the aftermath of the cree
squirrel war
leading up to the civil war event in
which tony stark assembled the leaders
from all corners of the marvel world
into a council
saying that all of them had information
pertaining to this alien war and they
could have prevented damage to earth
have they just shared notes
this council included tony stark leader
of the avengers
doctor strange sorcerer supreme of earth
professor charles xavier leader the
x-men
reed richards leader of the fantastic
four namor king of atlantis
and black bolt king of the inhumans they
also included black panther and
originally convened in wakanda
but t'challa backed out viewing the
illuminati is too self-righteous
and he feared what would happen if they
were all in agreement now when that word
illuminati appeared on tony stark's
phone in iron man 2 many began to
speculate that this could be in
development by kevin feige at marvel
studios and when he was asked about it
before doctor strange's release in 2016
feige said that he would have to wait to
introduce more of these names as mcu
canon and give them time to get to know
each other which infinity war would
start to do with tony stark and steven
strange
and some have now speculated this could
be in development for marvel phase four
perhaps at the end of doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness says steven
strange struggles to protect this planet
and this reality in the aftermath of
avengers end game but i believe that
this would still be
too soon like with tony stark dead
strange as even fewer members of the
illuminati left standing in the present
mcu we need some time to introduce the
fantastic four the x-men namor etc
before we care about their leaders
forming this secret club
and of course there's the deeper issue
with any illuminati adaptation that we
haven't talked about
the cue on elephant in the room yeah
illuminati is a term that marvel studios
might not want to be associated or
confused with like i get it back in 2005
the concept of a shadowy cabal called
the illuminati orchestrating world
events was fun fringy conspiracy fiction
from like dan brown novels
in 2020 well i am no longer allowed to
accidentally gesture like this
or like this without some of those 4chan
researchers screen grabbing me and using
my face to like sell supplements
just trust me disney and marvel do not
want their new superhero property to
trend on twitter whenever
rogan parts something about bill gates
animated series like archer on fx spent
years with its spy organization in the
show named isis and then in 2014 they
had to drop the name when news events
associated the name isis with something
else
i just would not be surprised if marvel
studios introduces the illuminati but
under a different name and i believe
they have already done that
see in the comics one of the first
actions of the illuminati is a
diplomatic mission
to the scrolls kindly requesting that
they stay the hell away from earth
and we have seen this kind of skrull
diplomacy in the mcu
actually the final most recent shot of
the mcu that we've seen on the big
screen
nick fury's space station filled with
skrulls in the post-credits scene of
spider-man apart from home
this space station is almost certainly
the peak the orbital headquarters of
sword sword is confirmed to play a role
in upcoming marvel titles based on set
photos for one division
sword is an offshoot of shield a play on
the old sword
and shield expression describing
military defense and offense
interestingly we got our first allusion
to that expression in the very
same moment that we saw tony stark's
illuminati file in iron man 2.
anthony stark has created a sword with
untold possibilities
and yet he insists it's a shield iron
man 2 was
filled with easter eggs that kevin feige
later used to establish further corners
of the marvel cinematic universe
it was our very first sighting of
wakanda popping up on nick fury's map in
that late scene a map that also showed a
region of
interest in the middle of the south
atlantic which many believe is a nod to
the existence of the kingdom of atlantis
and the screenwriters confirmed that
okoye's line in avengers endgame was a
seed that they planted for namor
it's an earthquake under the ocean we
handle it
by not handling it and of course this is
about the 3 000th time we've rolled this
deleted clip from iron man 2. i need
some stuff out of storage
give me everything from projects pegasus
exodus and goliath with project exodus
being the only shield operation still
unidentified and i speculate it could
refer to a weapon x type program
establishing mutants and thus professor
charles xavier in the mcu
in nick fury's alternate line in the
iron man post credits scene also hinted
at this
as if gamma accidents radioactive bug
bites and assorted mutants weren't
enough
so consider that from the moment nick
fury tried to recruit iron man for
shield tony stark conceived of his
own private world security force as a
contingency
we know stark had his own operation
going because he
hacked shield servers on the helicarrier
in the first avengers he didn't trust
shield just like he didn't trust any
other part of the american government
including the senate and he so
distrusted these folks that he kept his
files on a file that he jokingly
nicknamed
illuminati being another tongue-in-cheek
file name from the constant jokester
reflecting his aims to bypass legit
elected government officials with his
own
merit-based shadow authority that he
thinks is a better move and while he
trusted few
tony stark did for the most part trust
nick fury and from iron man 2
stark became aware of contacts in
wakanda contacts in the south atlantic
contacts on the mutant side of the world
and when justin hammer invoked
sword and shield tony stark finally got
the new name of his backup authority
sword sword could be marvel's illuminati
part of tony stark's legacy carried out
by nick fury
sword's first mission make peace with
the skrulls
and the ongoing cree squirrel war that
taylors and sword alluded to in that
throwaway line and far from home
i thought cree having sleeper cells was
top secret information nick and the
upcoming scroll secret invasion
maybe coming as soon as captain marvel 2
in summer 2022 which would all lead to a
phase 5
avengers 5 story maybe sometime 2023
2024
in which a new lineup will be marvel's
illuminati or as
we will call them the new avengers of
sword swords predecessor shield was
overseen by nick fury in that world
security council but now
imagine those talking heads to be dr
steven strange sorcerer supreme
king t'challa of wakanda the black
panther or maybe his surrogate
okoye one of the eternals icarus maybe
ajax the mcu's new reed richards
hopefully john krasinski
namor whom some believe could be
introduced in black panther 2
and an mcu charles xavier bald head of
the mutants
assuming he's recast from stuart or
mcavoy do you love the idea of brian
cranston or even giancarlo esposito tony
stark might even show up again
encoded as an ai algorithm of himself to
like holla project into meetings and
crash it
maybe even force them to give him a vote
kind of like zola or
jarvis he could live on as a saucy
immortal os
a post-mortem contingency from tony
stark to entrust the planet's security
in the safest hands that started all the
way back with a little icon on that lg
phone in iron man 2.
join this conversation on our official
discord server by becoming a patron at
patreon.com
follow me on instagram eavoss follow new
rockstars on socials and subscribe to me
rockstars for theories about ant-man 3
thor 4 martha r and do see marvel's
illuminati kick roadie off the zoom call
when he makes another boom joke i'm like
boom you looking for this
[Music]
you